bonjour je m'appelle Angelica ricobourg
société création je suis organisatrice
et coordinatrice de mariage j'ai créé
mon entreprise le en novembre 2013 et ça
fonctionne pas mal alors l'originalité
la force c'est la qualité de mes
prestations
de la coordination que j'emmène à mes
clients en fait parce que je cherche du
haut de gamme et il y en a très peu sur
la Réunion c'est pour ça que je me suis
principalement
intéressé à le challenge parce que ça me
permettrait déjà aux côtés organisation
avoir du monde avec moi au moins une
assistante et puis ben
enfin comment vous dire ça
élargir mais
mon entreprise sur la décoration